Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's mal ein außerplanmäßiges Video weil ich sehe überall diesen Dalgona Coffee
und ihr wisst ja ich bin ein riesen Coffee Junkie und ich muss den jetzt einfach mal ausprobieren!
Ich bin ja eigentlich so der Latte Machiato Fan - Latte Macchiato Fan!
Aber jetzt probieren wir das mal und zwar ist das eigentlich ein "Rezept" -
das ist eigentlich kein Rezept, das ist einfach so ein... drei
so ein Trend aus drei Bestandteilen und zwar hab ich hier lösliches Kaffeepulver,
das kommt jetzt direkt in die Schüssel. Dann haben wir hier noch Zucker und heißes Wasser,
gerade aufkochen lassen. Das geb ich jetzt auch da rein,
Und dann wird das ganz einfach verrührt, ich nehm mir jetzt - also ihr könnt auch ne Maschine nehmen,
das wär kein Problem. Würde sogar schneller gehen!
Aber ich nehm mir jetzt einfach mal den Schneebesen.
So und jetzt die ganze Zeit umrühren und irgendwann wird das mega cremig!
(K: Hamza rührt! Seht euch das mal an!)
Boah ich kann nicht mehr, das ist voll anstrengend!
(K: Ja, deswegen teilen wir uns ja auch die Arbeit!)
Der Mixer ist doch besser!
Ich bin jetzt die ganze Zeit hier am Rühren gewesen mit meinem Arm, ja?
Das war jetzt richtig anstrengend!
(H: Du hast auch keinen Mixer benutzt!)
Nein! Nein!
(H: *überzeugt* Okay!)
Und jetzt hab ich hier so ne richtig schöne, fluffige Masse! Schaut euch das mal an.
Schön hell-cremig. Und eigentlich machen wir jetzt nur noch folgendes:
Wir nehmen uns jetzt 2 Gläser mit Eiswürfeln und geben da jetzt ganz einfach
Milch rein, das mach ich jetzt hier direkt.
Ihr könntet auch Kakao nehmen, das ist auch eine gute Idee. Also nehmt auch gerne Kakao.
Nehmt gerne auch heiße Milch und dann diesen "kalt" gewordenen Schaum drauf, das ist auch sehr geil.
So, und dann geben wir das einfach nur noch drauf!
Und das war's schon!
(H: Wie das war's schon?)
Das war's Hamza! Das ist es gewesen!
(H: Das war das Rezept?)
Deswegen sag ich ja das ist kein Rezept streng genommen!
(H: Okay..)
So und jetzt einmal drauf...
So und jetzt einfach nur noch genießen, das sieht so lecker aus!
Und natürlich an die Umwelt denken, deswegen nehme ich jetzt hier auch einen Glas-Strohhalm
und dann schlürfe ich das jetzt schön aus!
Mmm! Mmm, das war jetzt nur Milch! Aber man muss sich das dann halt so ein bisschen verrühren.
Es sieht einfach auch cool aus, muss man dazu sagen!
(H: Ich glaub das ist eher so ein TikTok
"Es sieht cool aus" TikTok Trend aber es schmeckt nicht so..)
Ja, genau!
(H: es schmeckt eher so nach...also nix besonderes wahrscheinlich!)
Also die Milch überwiegt halt mega aber wenn ihr das verrührt,
doch, dann schmeckt's echt lecker, doch!
Also es ist... man weiß ja, wie's schmeckt.
Im Prinzip ist es ja wirklich nur löslicher Kaffee mit viel Zucker und Milch.
(H: Es ist einfach nur das Aussehen!)
Ja! Ja, das Aussehen.
Hier zählt mal das Aussehen, so. So ist es!
So jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen, probiert's gerne mal aus.
Schreibt mal in die Kommentare, welchen TikTok Trend ich als nächstes machen soll,
wir hatten jetzt -
(H: Und markiert uns!)
Und markiert uns, genau! Wir hatten jetzt das Cinnamon Bread, dann hatten wir - Ich ess schon hier meine Haare! -
das Cinnamon Bread, das war auch ein TikTok Trend! Dann hatten wir jetzt das hier und dann...
das dritte, das dürft ihr entscheiden!
(H: Da gibt's ja so einen Käse oder sowas, das man paniert
aber das ist auch nichts besonderes!)
Hmm...TikTok Trends sind irgendwie nie wirklich aufwendig, ne?
(H: Egaal!)
Egaal! So, jetzt verabschiede ich mich
und wir sehen uns bei meinem nächsten Video!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!